thanks will as small businesses work to
reopen their doors after pandemic
lockdowns they're running into a new
problem
bloated unemployment benefits are
actually hurting their ability to get
employees back to work
john michael brunetti is the co-owner of
rock and taco in roswell georgia and
he's seeing the problem
firsthand and joins us now john michael
thank you for being here and i love that
restaurant name by the way it's pretty
cool
so thanks for joining us this morning
but so let's ask you what has been the
implication on your business to these
long-term unemployment benefits that
people are receiving
um as we're opening back up number one
thank you very much for having me but uh
as we're opening back up we're starting
to see that people have been
patiently waiting to get back out and um
they're excited to get back out but that
also means that we're seeing an influx
of people that need to be
taken care of as guests when they come
into the restaurant and it's been
impossible to find
someone that would like to work
so what do you think as a business owner
what should be done here obviously
you're going to have a lot of people
coming out and saying
that many suffered as a result of the
pandemic as a result
of government shutdowns of of the
economy of businesses so those
unemployment benefits are needed so you
have to weigh the two things what would
be your proposed solution as a business
owner right now
um i 100 agree that i do understand that
people do need the money to make sure
that they uh
can get all their bills paid and make
sure they have food on the table but at
some point after the stimulus checks
have gone out
people are making more on unemployment
than we would be able to pay them
to come off of unemployment so the
biggest thing that we've seen is that
people
don't want to work for the money when
they can make just as much or more
sitting in their house so at some point
i think it's supposed to expire in
september but that's
the end of the summer that's after all
the russians has come in so
it needs to be some kind of plan where
we slowly roll back these unemployment
benefits
so it forces people to say hey we're
back open
it's time to get back to work yeah and
that's an important conversation
that we're having right now about
whether we're disincentivizing work
and what the implications of that will
be long-term one thing that's really
interesting about your bio to me is that
you're also a
financial advisor would you be able to
speak to a little bit
what you're seeing from that angle in
terms of what people are actually doing
with stimulus money when it gets in
their hands are they spending it are
they investing it what's happening
actually behind the scenes
investing it because there are a lot of
people that uh
didn't need it or weren't expecting it
and all of a sudden they get a stimulus
check
in their checking account so therefore
they are
reinvesting it they're putting the stock
market into some of these
um i have different uh game stops and
things like that that's the number one
call that we get is hey can we
can we get on some of these hot stocks
and that's just not the way that it
works
but uh less people are putting the money
into the economy which is what the
purpose of it was but
more people are definitely definitely
using it to uh invest
in their savings so that's definitely
something i've seen at true vestment so
do you have any advice to people finally
from
the perspective of a business owner
we've had a lot of business owners on
the show
who've struggled uh and we can all
understand why through the pandemic but
advice to them
from a business perspective and a
financial advisor perspective right now
in these difficult times as the economy
starts to reopen and
people have some trepidation about what
to do and how to approach it because
they're not sure what's coming down the
pike in the next few months
oh i mean absolutely that's every
business owner is
walking on eggshells because uh they
don't know if there's more money coming
to help them
or if it's going to be uh the end of it
or if they just need to
open back up without limitations we're
waiting on that with the state of
georgia which i feel like we're very
close but
the biggest thing is just to hold on i
feel like there's a lot of people that
are understanding of the situation that
a lot of people are going through but um
hold on try to find the employees try to
make the guests happy when they come in
but
um it's i feel like we're getting to the
end so don't give up on us now
john michael brunetti that's some great
advice thank you for being here rock and
taco
listen i like a little rock and roll
with my tacos so if i'm ever in the
neighborhood i'm coming on down
thanks for being here sounds great